so you're scouring the internet trying
to figure out what to watch this weekend
you can stop because we got you covered
from horde action to like whatever this
is here's what's new in movies and TV
this week you like The Hunger Games well
good nerve feels like The Hunger Games
in the 21st century you have a teenage
girl playing a social game online and of
course things get out of control quickly
so watch this movie and then immediately
go to leet your account this thriller is
packed with action and teen drama the
best kind of drama it's the truth or
dare game without all the truth and
there's some cameos of internet stars
are you a watcher or are you a player we
recommend watching and nerve is out in
theaters as of July 27th born he's back
you thought he was gone that's dumb he's
back he'll never die and even though
Matt Damon only has like 25 lines in
this new flick we don't watch these
films for the dialogue we watch him for
the Damon but with that being said the
bourne series usually nailed it with
those twists and turns in the plot and
some intense action so you can enjoy
your popcorn while born destroys his
enemies become the bourne on july twenty
ninth guess what kind of movie this is
yup you guessed it it's one of those
zombie things the world is infected with
a devastating virus and there are some
survivors this film comes from the mines
that brought you the purge and insidious
so you can expect to see some things
that you wish you hadn't but hey who
doesn't like a good nightmare viral is
infecting box offices on July 29 now I
know we've got a lot of silly stuff on
this show but if you're looking for
something more educational a little bit
deeper you're [ __ ] out of luck because
sharknado for is coming out you wouldn't
believe that they could keep making
these but they just keep coming up with
new ideas to kill sharks oh my god let's
see that again yeah that's a crotch kill
believe it or not the sci-fi channel
produces these so you can watch this
right from your couch so sit back and
watch your favorite b-list celebrities
get annihilated by sharks
all these hot pics which one of you guys
gonna watch this weekend let me know in
the comments below and for everything
entertainment you're going to want to
stay tuned to gamespot universe so don't
forget to subscribe i'll see you guys
again next week happy watching